[Musique]
alors comment faire pour que demain soit
un rêve plutôt qu'un cauchemar car
effectivement le cauchemar il est
possible il est possible comme pour ces
gens sur cette plage vous voyez ici un
père de famille qui fait un geste du
bras et vous voyez une personne en
bikini noir et une autre qui tend la
main vers l'horizon et il ya un bateau
qui me sert de marqueur temporel donc je
peux vous dire que et bien l'image
suivante a été prise 10 secondes après
la famille a disparu
une troisième personne est apparu dans
le champ eh bien chers amis c'est trois
personnes sont déjà mortes
elles ne savent pas sont encore tout à
fait vivante mais en fait elles sont
déjà mortes elles sont déjà mortes parce
que ce que vous voyez à l'horizon c'est
le tsunami de 2004 cette photo a été
prise à 10 heures du matin le 26
novembre 2004 sur une plage de thaïlande
est le père de famille avait compris ça
fait longtemps sur terre qui a fait un
grand dynamisme il avait compris fait
évacuer sa famille les autres à un
regard et un truc à l'horizon a vu ses
étranges et maïs sont déjà morts mais la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que beaucoup
d'entreprises sont déjà mortes et elles
ne savent pas encore est donc beaucoup
de gens ont perdu leur travail et ne
savent pas encore pourquoi parce qu'un
tsunami qui arrivait ce tsunami
c'est en fait cinq grandes révolutions
qui convergent en même temps il ya
justement la révolution des sciences de
la complexité
le fait qu'on n'a pas les bons gps pour
naviguer dans un monde complexe parce
qu'on se sert des outils du monde de
hyères d'un monde qui était nettement
plus simples où il y avait nettement
moins d'interactions c'est comme si vous
naviguez la nuit sur la mer et bien le
port gba c'est faux vous avez forcément
dans un rocher beaucoup de décideurs
politiques et du privé n'ont pas les
bons gps pour naviguer dans ce monde
complexe il y à une révolution
conceptuelle affaire il ya une
révolution technologique
allez voir qu'il ya quatre internet et
pas seulement celui que vous connaissez
une révolution économique c'est une
bonne nouvelle parce que l'imagination
humaine prend plus de poids que la
machine que des capitaux c'est ce qu'on
appelle le post capitalisme et cela
implique une révolution managériale on
ne peut pas un manager
et comme superman qui va éteindre un
incendie partout il faut passer d'un
modèle de chef de chef tout puissant un
chef d'orchestre qui met en musique les
compétences de ses salariés et enfin une
révolution sociétale le passage de
l'avoir à l'être j'existe parce que je
veux être seul à vivre seul à incarner
cela et non pas parce que j'ai une
ferrari un sac louis vuitton ou un sac
chanel ce sont 5 grande révolution
sociétale managériale technologiques
économiques et conceptuel qui arrivent
en même temps et évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui perturbe beaucoup mais
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait encore
être allé beaucoup plus loin car pour
écrire un ouvrage les clés du futur
j'ai lu 200 ouvrages et celui qui m'a le
plus impressionné c'est celui ci de
james baratte notre dernière invention
l'intelligence artificielle et la fin de
l'ère humaine qu'est ce que dit james
part at il dit que c'est une agence
d'artistes et des possibles elle
pourrait prendre le contrôle de la
planète et nous éliminer comme nous
traitons nous mêmes les chimpanzés
est ce parce que nous considérons comme
inférieures alors vous avez c'est de la
science fiction
on a déjà vu ça au cinéma oui justement
on a vu un skynet terminator etc
mais des gens aussi sérieux que donne
mais ce que des jeux que bill gates que
stephen hawking 10 mais c'est pas parce
qu'on a vu au cinéma que ça n'existe pas
méfiez-vous
vous avez déjà des campagnes d'amnistié
internationale contre les robots tueurs
par exemple un des petites bestioles
comme ça comme qui sont faites avec les
financements de l'armée américaine la
darpa vous mettez des mitrailleuses
dessus et poum vous c'est parti et c'est
eux qui appuie sur le bouton c'est pas
comme les drones il ya quelqu'un qui
appuie sur le bouton
c'est cet animal entre guillemets lui
même qui décide qui doit tuer voyez là
on est évidemment sur des questions
éthiques et très grave mais heureusement
et technologies elles sont ce que nous
en faisons
vous avez aussi des possibilités comme
ici vous voyez le premier cyborg au
monde on parlait de seaboard en science
fiction est bien et ce qui c'était a
perdu ses deux bras cet homme là on lui
pose des bras robots qui sont contrôlés
par son cerveau c'est une première
mondiale
john hopkins national laboratory aux
états unis
c'est à dire qu'en fait il contrôle des
mouvements de bras par son cerveau donc
ça veut dire que demain il y aura plus
de paralyser de tétraplégique
paraplégique
parce que c'est une rupture de la moelle
épinière que l'on est capable de bypass
et maintenant vous avez encore par
exemple à l'université du minnesota
ici c'est cet étudiant on regarde très
fixe parce que effectivement et
l'ordinateur lycée penser en permanence
pour contrôler le drone que vous voyez
qui circulent entre les ballons donc
s'il pense à sa petite amie et bien le
drone se casse la gueule
donc il doit être très concentré toutes
ces nouvelles technologies
elles sont parfois impressionnantes mais
sont parfois aussi extraordinaire garder
comme pour ces gamins qui sont nés sans
leurs mains et pouvez imprimer
aujourd'hui des mains pour 5 $ sur une
imprimante qui vaut 600 $ alors que la
prothèse valait 20 mille dollars
et ça c'est la révolution de
l'imprimante 3d et où vous n'avez pas
idée du nombre de choses que l'on peut
imprimer en imprimantes 3d ici vous
voyez par exemple une maison
dix maisons comme ça peuvent être
imprimées par une imprimante la grande
barre verticale que vous voyez plus
incroyable encore vous n'allez pas me
croire et pourtant certains d'entre vous
ont peut être déjà vu une oreille
humaine louis une oreille humaine peut
être imprimé par une imprimante 3d très
différent bien sûr cette imprimante là
qui prend des morceaux de votre peau
cultive les cellules prend les cellules
une par une et mais sur une grille en
forme d'oreilles et hop vous avez une
oreille si vous avez perdu est la vôtre
vous avez aussi cette possibilité qui a
été fait
même moi d'imprimer des vertèbres
cervicales sur une imprimante 3d qui ont
été implantés et qui ont sauvé la vie
d'un patient australiens qui avaient un
cancer des os
donc vous voyez st c'est une révolution
mais il y en a une dernière qui arrivent
par rapport à ces quatre internet c'est
la révolution de l'internet de l'énergie
vous avez ici un arbre avant c'est une
chaque petite feuille verte est une mini
éolienne
vous pouvez mettre ça dans votre jardin
c'est pas comme les grands mâts éoliens
de 60 mètres de haut qui défigurent le
paysage on peut mettre sur le toit des
villes discrètement issy les moulineaux
et vous avez la smart flower qui vous
fait de l'énergie
électrique en panneaux solaires comme un
tournesol intelligent qui suit le soleil
et qui retourne dans sa boîte quand
c'est terminé
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le smart
grid le réseau intelligent et demain on
va donc c'est changer de l'énergie comme
aujourd'hui on s'échange des emails donc
vous voyez internet que tout le monde
connaît internet des objets connectés
quand ça ne va pas être une lome
connectés comme je voulais montrer
internet des objets fabriqués par
internet et internet de l'énergie déjà
des révolutions technologiques qui
seront là en 2030 et qui vont changer
radicalement notre vie parce que nous le
voyons déjà à des prémices de tout ceci
avec jeudi des maisons imprimé en 24
heures c'est déjà aujourd'hui c'est pas
demain alors vous avez aussi dans la
révolution économique un sujet qui est
passionnant et qui me tient beaucoup à
coeur c'est ce que j'appelle l'écologie
positive
voilà un numéro où william mcdonough
août et une de ses réalisations le plus
grand toit vert du monde c'est un toit
pour une usine ford qui dépollue l'eau
utilisée par l' usine en passant par les
trois jours au milieu des plantes
chaque plante enlève un type de
polluants mais aussi qui aspire l'air de
la ville louis qui aspire l'air de la
ville pour le filtré à travers la terre
du toit enlever des particules vous
rendez compte plus cette usine va
fonctionner plus l'air sera dépollué
c'est un changement radical de vision
être bon ou être moins mauvais je
m'explique
mcdonough de vous dis hein eh bien
demain les écologistes les chefs
d'entreprise trinqueront quand on va
mettre en place une nouvelle usine
parce qu'elle des polluera l'air et
l'eau en fonctionnant c'est pas de
polluer moins
vous comprenez c'est de même pas de pas
polluer du tout non non c'est de
restaurer la nature en fonctionnant
demain quand il y aura essayé existe pas
en combien de petites fonctions comme ça
sur un nouvelle tesla
quand il y aura une voiture à écologie
positive madame anne hidalgo ne pourra
plus faire des journées sans voiture
dans paris parce que plus il y aura de
voiture puis la ville sera dépollué
c'est pas les voitures électriques c'est
qu'ils polluent passer des voitures qui
vont dépolluer enroulé envoyé aux herses
est un rêve et pourtant regardez
julien de mercury ce jeune ingénieur il
ya un peu trop un tennis de lui vous
montrer qu'ils ont entre les mains sa
découverte c'est une feuille
artificielle voulu éclairer vous
l'éclairer avec le soleil
duy de l'oxygène à partir du gaz
carbonique des villes comme le fait tout
feuilles vous recouvrez une maison avec
sa aux explique-t-il et vous transformer
la maison en arbre et vous avez le
brevet européen de l'année 2015 de
marquer au caire c'est ce béton avec des
bactéries
quand il y fonde y est abîmée nous
rentrer dedans elle fait revivifier
bactéries qui vont combler le trou tout
seul en produisant du calcium
on peut faire des murs vivent des murs
qui dépollue l'air d'une ville et des
murs qui sautent aurait pas vous rendez
compte
un autre de mes grands héros gunter
pauli un titre à faire hurler de rage un
écologiste vous rendez compte croissance
sans limite
non mais quelle horreur c'est pas
possible on peut pas avoir le beurre et
l'argent du beurre
et bien si on peut faire une croissance
économique et une régénération la nature
d'abord parce que vous explique gunter
pauli une grande partie de ce que nous
produisons 70% ce qu'on fait pousser
dans les champs est gâché dans le cas du
café c'est encore bien pire c'est 99 %
ont de café que vous venez de bois 1 1%
dans votre ventre le reste le marc de
café
et bien cette jeune africaine chili de
gouvernants à trouver comment faire
pousser des champignons sur du marc de
café et était la première d'une terre
poli fasciné l'a aidé et à partir de ce
moment là et bien mis en en place la
marque de shilo c'est le premier café au
monde qui est consigné vous le buvez
vous le rende et le marc de café ont
fait pousser des champignons avec ce qui
reste on fait des vêtements textiles et
avec ce qui reste du textile encore du
marc de café
eh bien on fait des semelles de
chaussures donc vous rendez compte on
est en pleine économie circulaire ici et
ce qui est vraiment intéressant dans ses
concepts c'est que vous avez vous
transformez les problèmes en solutions
par exemple on va vous dire les
touristes les touristes sont un problème
parce qu'il abîme l'environnement et
bien dans ce là ce qu'on fait on limite
le tourisme et bien non ici vous avez
dans l'île de bonaire un projet
supervisé par gunter pauli vous avez
dans cette île une ferme de coraux on
invite tous les touristes la visite et
on leur dit vous voulez vous un diplôme
de forrester de la mer c'est très chic
re forrester de la mer alors oui
absolument à vous prenez les coraux vous
allez partout dans la ville où il ya des
pics et vous plongez vous les accrocher
et voilà
plus il y aura de touristes plus il y
aura de coraux on peut parfaitement
faire ça dans un parc naturel régional
en france voyez vous et ça ce sont des
idées en fait vraiment c'est une
question d'innovation d'intelligence de
créativité regardez vous avez ici du
papier à base de pierres 80% en poudre
de pierre 20 % de déchets péter pas un
seul végétal ne rentre dans la
composition ce papier pas d'eau pour le
faire oui
les solutions sont partout et ça c'est
formidable quand on regarde cette
possibilité pour le monde de demain
mais dans un monde où il ya des tunnels
minot un monde où les cartes sont
rebattues
c'est aussi beaucoup plus facile de
réussir parfois c'est presque incroyable
voici jean baptiste rudelle c'est un ami
d'enfance j'étais au lycée avec lui en
2012 je reprends contact et je lui
demande qu'est ce que tu deviens news
une petite start up en californie un an
après 2 5 milliards de dollars de
valorisation pour l'entreprise fondée et
dirigée par mon ami d'enfance jean
baptiste rudelle 2.5 milliards pourquoi
parce qu'il est capable de rassembler
l'information la traiter et la revendre
plus rapidement que d'autres
vous avez donc ce potentiel
extraordinaire que l'on retrouve aussi
par exemple dans les possibilités de
financement collaboratif avant par
exemple quand on était jeune étudiant
vous deviez travailler ensuite 25 ans
dans une entreprise d'électronique avant
de faire votre société
là vous avez des montres people fait par
trois jeunes étudiants qui au lieu
d'aller travailler ont mis un beau
projet sur kickstarter.com et ont
récolté 12 millions de dollars à côté
vous avez la glacière de coups laisse 12
5 millions de dollars
des gens qui auraient eu besoin de faire
une étude de marché un emprunt bancaire
et de donner une part de leur boîte à un
business angel comme l'a fait mon ami
jean baptiste rudelle donc vous avez 50
% de votre boîte qui a disparu en même
que vous avez vendu quelque chose eh ben
non
aujourd'hui vous faites un projet qui
fonctionne et à tous les niveaux
voilà un breton qui voyait 8000 euros
pour faire de la bière il a eu 25 mille
euros des croates qui voulaient 25000
dollars pour faire un mug en forme de
corne de chair ils ont eu deux cent
cinquante mille dollars
donc évidemment vous avez des
possibilités incroyables et ce n'est pas
réservé aux gens bac + 15 csp + etc
chris anderson et le directeur de tmx
reste un passionné de drones et chris
anderson discuter avec quelqu'un
ça n'est pas acceptée sur internet qu'il
donnait des idées pour faire des cartes
de contrôle des chroniques de drones est
au bout d'un certain temps il dit mais
tu es qui toi à moi je suis jordi munoz
19 ans je suis un sans-papier mexicain
je vis dans une caravane los angeles et
je communique avec toi par le wifi
gratuit du mcdonald's qui au dessus de
ma cave et bien je redis munoz et
aujourd'hui chef d'une entreprise qui
fait des drones et qui est financé par
chris anderson bien évidemment vous avez
ici kevin d'eau et 15 ans du sierra
leone qui tient dans les mains sa grande
découverte une batterie fait avec des
déchets métalliques qui a permis
d'électrifier tout son village avec des
déchets métalliques et il a fait
utiliser du coca cola pour remplacer
l'acide de batterie et oui ça marche
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas d'acide
évidemment il a écrit fier son village
ont invité om haïti pour expliquer
comment ça fonctionne
kevin d'eau et 15 en sierra leone shido
gouvernement du zimbabwe jordi munoz
mexicain sans papiers voyez le monde de
demain et plein de potentiel monde de
demain est ouvert mais le monde de
demain a aussi bien entendu des risques
vous avez vu les robots tueurs voyez
prometic que peuvent poser aussi ce
genre de choses alors c'est ici un
moment crucial de l'évolution humaine
vous avez cette fameuse vision de
millions d'années d'évolution qui amène
à l'homo sapiens ce qu'il faudrait
éviter
puisqu'on parle de rêve ou de cauchemar
ce qu'il faudrait éviter c'est que
l'homo sapiens se retourne et 10 à ses
ancêtres demi-tour et gars c'était un
piège
l'évolution dans un cul-de-sac eh bien
non nous avons la possibilité de faire
que cette évolution nous amène à un
monde rêvé à mon nom sera tellement bien
qu'on devra parvenir en 2016
mais pour cela c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
faut faire les choix essentiels
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il faut donner
raison à pierre teilhard de chardin car
il vous disait pierre teilhard de
chardin quand vous voyez le monde autour
de vous vous voyez des convulsions dans
le monde
ces convulsions ça peut être le signe
d'une maladie quand vous êtes en pleine
convulsion
mais la convulsion c'est aussi le signe
d'un possible enfantement donc oui à
nous de faire que lui nul donnons raison
en disant que le monde n'est pas malade
parce qu'il va enfanter
merci
[Applaudissements]